all systems go
all systems go
hello everyone how's everyone today
hopefully ready for another exciting
class on another word of physics I'm
sorry mathematics that's not that's not
God over there that's prodding me that's
my son well no it sounds great because
it sounds like God is talking to me fine
yeah I'm really I'm receiving all this
from God so you know you better believe
what I'm saying here well I can put
subtitles there you mean like I'm just
saying like editing all these videos
anyways what do we have we had field we
had force
yeah I'm fielding force
a couple weeks ago we had time and mass
okay so we cover those and and we have
field force and what's the other one
what am I missing field force time mass
and I'm missing one more energy
obviously energy energy was the first
one we dealt with this week and today we
have charge charge
first I'll give you the only than nuts
and bolts of what I think a lame yeah
what do you think charges let's see what
what do you think charges that's a good
way to start what is charge bundle of
energy whoa bundle of energy bundle hey
could you hand me that bundle here that
Sanders charged in batteries or no
battery you can give me I'm just
thinking you just give me charged I
don't want the battery I just want to
charge holding charge by Atlus he's
holding charge you know that he's
holding something like that it's like
it's like holding a place where where
energy is is concentrated you know
potential movement yeah but that could
be grab it to you right also I mean
charge is not great electric charges
this is not gravity can't really have a
charge no no that's my point my point is
but that's my point my point is that
what you just described can be applied
also to gravity and that's not charge so
you can't say oh no why not like
concentrated that's what I'm saying but
that's what gravity is attention
movement you know it's also potential
you don't have to move to receive grab
it right that's actually there's a
potential in every spot in space right
but that's different than the potential
movement we
we talked about charge which is it could
use its charge but it isn't yet like
I've got to stored within yeah and
that's not really the point in space a
point in space is more like predictable
they could but then you can also say
well I guess that would be charged also
but see you got you know I've got the
magnetism inside me and for sure as well
if I've got electricity I mean you know
a lot of my biological processes are
electrical and that means that you know
if it wherever you see electricity you
have to have magnetism so I have a
magnetism within me as well as that
stored magnetism but that's what
potential means essentially because if
you talk about electricity we've got the
same situation what do you mean by
stored or potential electricity think
the Dominos it's predictable chain of
events that you can kind of foresee that
if you put this in a certain you can
predict that the dominoes will fall and
they'll have this you know flowing
energy where I recall that that's really
over time oh we're talking about
potential we're talking about
predictable useful I'd like to use the
word spirit always for all those
potential because they're all concepts
[Music]
oh it is oh I'm so sorry
yeah because was it a strongly not to
contend with the issue what what is the
notion that's true that's true and you
can't really just experience no no it's
not here totally correct in that sense
what I'm saying is every time we use
words such as energy
the force field all these concepts yeah
I can just replace them very easily with
the word spirit and I'm okay I should be
fine now that doesn't mean that we have
to elude or avoid explaining what's
causing it right all I'm saying is when
these people use the word energy they're
avoiding that defining or telling us
what it is we have to we have to contend
with charge spirit but you like spirit
because it kind of takes away that we
already know what it is kind of thing
and that's what that's why I like to put
the wig back that's why I like the word
the word spirit because it opens or I'll
show you what charge is okay we have
charge here in front of you here it is
drum roll please
here it is that's charge so if you ever
wanted to know what charge is there you
have it it looks like a spider or a
spider's web or something like that and
looks like a little bug I would think
and the left hand side you have the
arrows going out as you can see in the
bottom picture lower left and has a
positive it's a positive looks like it
at least though it's got a cross or
something maybe it's in a crusade and
one on the right is blue and it has a
negative sign I invent them I create
them you know so that people can see
what what they look like no these are
these are their pictures these are their
yeah the mathematicians this with the
illustrate so if you want to know what
charge is you look it up and this is
what you see and you say well what am i
staring at you know a bunch of arrows
Indian arrows I guess what's the context
of this picture like where did where was
it taken from magnet taken out of the
Wikipedia Wikipedia out the word
electric charge that's what they show
you this is electric charge that's the
representation of
charge charge being no it's the
potential for electricity it's what and
an electron has in fact I have a better
picture see this is this is a drawing
let me show you now I'm gonna show you a
photograph of charge okay here's a
photograph of charge okay now now look
at that isn't that beautiful
now when I looked at this I said you
know it looks like a couple boobs in the
night you know that's what it looked
like to me and you know when I when I
went in there and I reversed the colors
affected me that's what I saw - hairy
boobs that's what they are you know so
so now you know what charge is it looks
like that it's quite ugly so let me take
that out of there
so we don't see it anymore yeah yeah
yeah I inverted the color and that's
what you get I mean what is that what is
that nonsense and and that's what they
illustrate that's what they take
pictures of and they say that's charge
and you're supposed to see these things
and not know what what they're really
talking about because charge is
something else and here we have a
definition as always we need to have
definitions I mean a little bit electric
charge is the physical property just
like yesterday they're all physical
properties right of matter that causes
it to experience a force when placed in
an electro magnetic field what is the
physical property it's any property
I like that physical property is a
property okay that is miserable whose
value describes a state of a physical
system and you know they add over there
that there are two types of electric
charges positive and negative and here
we confirm that in these in this picture
right you can see it's positive and
negative right especially the two bottom
ones you can see that maybe that's where
I gotta make it sure there we go so we
have the positive negative charge right
like charges repel Dan unlike attract
and in abjectly with an absence of net
charge is referred to as neutral so I
must be neutral because I don't charge
anything it's my wife who does all the
charging so so what is all this about I
mean what are they talking about
does Mother Nature understand what
positive and negative is would she
recognize these little dots with arrows
going out and inwards as what she does
out there every day you know what is all
this this this abstraction what does
this have to do with physics and you
know it turns out that you know like it
says electric charge is a physical
property physical property is any
property that is measurable whose value
blah blah blah blah blah so they're
talking about numbers they're talking
about units that's what it is and for
them to try to illustrate numbers and
units and turn it into what you see at
the bottom there you know this charge
here you know it's it's just kind of
ridiculous because you can't illustrate
it and what this shows one more time is
that mathematics is not the language of
physics it's not the language of
physical interpretations you cannot use
math an equation a number a variable you
cannot use anything coming out of the
entire mathematical world to explain a
phenomenon of nature you can describe it
but you cannot explain it you can't tell
me the cause you cannot explain the
mechanism how something works by using
mathematics anybody part of mathematics
just I'll let you use anything ever
invented in mathematics in the last
10,000 years you cannot use it to
explain math can only describe and so to
try to convert those mathematical
symbols equations variables numbers
whatever constants to try to convert
those into a physical representation in
other words to unify math with physics
mathematical physics that's where the
crime is committed
isn't that kind of the best that they
have to go off of where they do their
calculations they find out they kind of
try to get what the properties of these
phenomenon are as close as they can the
descriptions of them you know someone
describes a chair well enough that you
can kind of imagine it in your head
without ever seeing one kind of thing
you know whether you try to approximate
it with numbers no no but hold it how do
you describe a chair with numbers in
such a way that the ET knows what you
mean by the word chair the guy is
imagining a lion you know not a chair I
mean he's got four legs he's got a back
rest you say then you would have to show
a movie you can't show him like you know
if I wouldn't show an ET a chair I would
show the et a chair in a static picture
I would say chair I'd point ahold let me
can you point and it says and you say
chair but if you're going to say look
you know I have an equation for a chair
and I can plug in numbers and I can
build a chair point by point and when I
finish D this you know putting numbers
in their array I have finally the chair
the the image that you're talking about
that's a movie in other words what I'm
doing is building the chair and I gotta
wait for your infinite numbers until you
plug in all the numbers from zero to at
least or maybe from one to infinity
until I know what a chair is not saying
it's perfect nothing okay if I have
enough parameters if I have enough like
calculations and descriptions of the
denominator I can kind of imagine it in
my head but even that is not science
because science is an explanation oh
yeah yeah and that's why we have to find
out what science is about I'm trying to
explain how they end up with these
do their calculation I get close as they
can with with their calculations by you
know extrapolating functions from each
other and then trying to explain food
described phenomenon as best they can
with enough descriptions they can make
the movie in their head where they can
then go okay I mean they don't think
much on the physical interpretation I'll
be the CEO else they wouldn't resort to
this but it's like I think they just
kind of take the sit though the easy
route okay here's ball X is ball y this
one does this this one does that we
don't care about the details we don't
care about the mechanism we just care
about describing the system they're just
trying to explain what one ball does to
the other without not nothing so it's
not the way I explained but yeah they're
just more interested in describing the
sequence of events so that we can use it
in some sort of tool or so that we can
show it to everyone you know if if I you
know if I was the first person to
discover magnetism I don't have to
explain it to show people what magnetism
is mean at least describe it to them but
you know that's what peregrinus did and
what is it
14th or 15th century I think it was and
he said positive attracts negative
essentially he was the one of the first
to come up with that notion and he and
all he did was he wrote a letter to his
friend that's what we have today and he
said look if you chop a magnet in half
you still have positive and negative
still the tracks that's what he said
he never explained anything but people
today say oh peregrine is the first one
to explain how a magnet works no he
never did he does a positive interaction
that's all you did that's all you did
that's well let's clarify I don't want
to go too deep into the policy no no no
but but let's clarify that at the turn
of the 19th to the 20th century right
had a revolution and what causes things
to happen and that was completely
finished at the turn of the 20th century
when you have the quantum 19
Oh that same year last year the 19th
century Max Planck discovers the that
light comes in little balls the bundles
of energy called quantum quanta and from
then on especially after the roaring 20s
physics became completely abstract and
in since then since the 20s at least
that's almost 100 years now it's all
been abstractions and like I said in a
previous video abstract abstract is
exactly the opposite an antonín of
physical so we went from physics to
abstract if they want to call it
abstract what they do that's fine but
don't tell me that you're doing physics
and this were the problems but we need
to this is important what you're saying
they kind of take the best they could
come up with but what does that mean one
is what does that mean they'll say down
say okay can anyone explain this
phenomenon no why don't they say that
see they don't say that they say we can
explain magnet works but and they say
positive attracts negative because it's
got domains and that's not an
explanation there's no way of knowing
you know you never know
[Laughter]
we don't know it's always what's the bet
I mean even you but I give an
explanation they're not giving
explanations
they're explanations are all [ __ ] as
a plan I'm saying if you have any
description I don't know because you
have some inkling of information you can
describe you can say I can describe it
yeah why don't they say that see they
don't say that to the public they say oh
we can explain and they're like a nuance
this but this is a description they
haven't understood that difference
that's that's something you kinda have
to bash your head against the wall
because wimping is work for me you know
I get two magnets here right and I from
yesterday we still have really quite
locked in but you know one thing is to
for you to describe you know the force
and say this is so much force and you
can measure it and relate it to other
pre-established units of measure and
whatever and you can describe the
strength of these magnets that's
different in Tommy what is the mechanism
by which a magnet attracts another from
a distance or repels it you know here I
can't even put them together does it so
so I think we should all be able to
understand at least that that there's a
difference between explanation and
description and they and they claim
there is a why I am because I only have
the scripts and then when they give the
physical interpretation the explanation
they give some irrationality and this is
you haven't hit on the nose but they
they actually believe that they have
explained some of these things and
others like you say they recognize like
in quantum that they can't explain and
they just abandon that line of work are
words right you can explain that can't
ya know you can you just that you could
literally tell someone and so far we
have description and all you do is
described so far yes that I know when in
order to explain you have to say and
this caused when you use the word cause
that changes every unit you don't ever
have to use the word cause you need to
literally just say for
that goes into that just describe the
whole band and the et still doesn't know
how a car works you just say this goes
here this goes here you got all these
descriptions you say okay but how does
the car run but and you still don't know
you have a running car and teach them
how to fix a car for example and that
still is not an Austronesian yeah it's
not an explanation but we can do
everything we need to the technology was
just description so they can I have no
problem where they just take the
description level of things and these go
okay that's all we need this is the
problem this is the problem they brushed
aside explanations as philosophy as
ontology as metaphysics it's
unexplainable pointed out to people this
is worse than that because the
explanation part it also falls outside
of technology so there's no use for the
explenation part as well also and and
this is the broaden the problem is that
the public at large out there is unaware
that there are no explanation a lot of
people come in you know laymen and they
say yeah they have here is an
explanation and they believe the
explanations
you know outrageous ones like you know
particles coming back from the future
they have no problem with these things
you know and and this is the problem
because now we lost track of reality we
were talking about charge when I was
rudely interrupted and you know one of
the things that we know about charge
that again like it said it's a number
it's a number in a quantity you talk
about the charge on an electron it was
measured to be one point six times ten
to the minus nineteen coulombs whatever
that is right just a unit and it's a
very small unit period that's all you
need to know in the case of the
electrons negative in the case of the
proton it's positive charge and I was
measured by Milligan Rob
Millikan of charge yeah on electro he
measured it on the electron but you know
since it's its counterpart as the proton
one has negative the other one positive
and again what does that mean what does
this mother need to understand what
negative and positive mean oh he could
have said X and y whatever he could you
know they could have put any signs they
wanted in there plus minus you know the
ampersand sign none of that has any
meaning to mother nature and and again
here's the oil-drop experiment carried
out by Milligan to measure the amount of
charge on the electron and this is a
very interesting experiment and that you
got to give the this fellow not really
him I'll clarify that in a second but
you gotta give them credit for for this
experiment what it is is on the left you
on the right I'm sorry on the left you
have microscope you know the right you
have an x-ray source the x-ray source
what it does is ionizes the air between
those two plates the brown plates there
one on the top one on the bottom and it
ionizing the air the oil drops which are
put in through that oil dropper there
that mist that's coming into the upper
chamber the oil drops fall in through
that hole on the upper plate and they
fall to the lower plate very simple
experiment in general for its design so
what happens the two plates are are
charged in other words you have a
voltage running through there and what
you can do with this is first ionize the
air the air then allegedly removes an
electron from the oil drop and you have
all sizes of oil drops you remove an
electron from that molecule and then you
can now you can manipulate the oil drop
and how you can manipulate it as follows
gravity pulls the oil drop down and by
applying the the charge the plates there
the bottom one is positive the negative
one is the
the one on the top you have a positive
ion in other words the the oil turns
into a positive charge essentially and
now you can manipulate it with the
voltage and you can pull the that that
drop upwards against gravity you see
what I'm saying here in other words you
have gravity the the drop Falls because
of gravity to the lower plate but you
can push it back up or you can keep it
up by applying a voltage such that the
negative plate is is the upper one pulls
on that drop Electric electrically you
know it pulls on and the other one
repels it on the bottom and by having
that voltage there run across from one
plate to the other you can pull it up
against the pull of gravity against its
own weight has negative has positive
because you remove that electron eyes
the air and you do this against gravity
gravity pulls it down and electricity
pushes it up when electricity exactly
matches the force of gravity there's an
equation that relates gravity to the
electrical charge it is that's why it's
a nice that's why it's very interesting
experiment incredible experiment that
you got to hand that to them and and
because of that they were able to remove
one electron two electrons three
electrons and they found out they were
multiples 1.6 times something always and
that's how they arrived at one point
saves 10 to the minus 19 coulombs okay
that's in a nutshell what they did here
and it's an interesting experiment under
any circumstance again there's a little
detail that needs to be to details that
need to be mentioned the first one is
that maybe three
Millikan received a Nobel Prize in 1923
for his work from 1909 to 1913 for this
experiment the Oh drop experiment for
determining the charge
the electron second he had a foul that
helped him his name was Harvey Fletcher
was a student of his and Harvey
apparently is the guy who came up with
most of the ideas if not all the
critical ideas and Milliken apparently
threatened him to not you know give him
his ph.d if unless Fletcher gave up the
rights to to the claim on the oil-drop
experiment okay
and and so Fletcher went on to do some
other stuff he eventually got his PhD
and went on to do work with sound you
work for Bell company in fact he was
given a recommendation by Milliken but
he wrote his own version of what
happened a few weeks before the the
experiment was published the results of
the experiment were published and
Milliken was the only guy who received
the Nobel Prize for it first and second
there's a second issue and that's that
apparently he cheated he cheated because
he threw away data that yeah
Milliken cheated he when he wrote his
paper he dismissed data that did not
fall in line with what he was predicting
or what he was publishing and so he he
left that data out and I was discovered
later on and his value 1 points ace up
whatever it was some decimal points
after that is today revised because of
the experiment has been done more
carefully and if he would have published
some of those other readings maybe he
would not have been accepted as well by
the scientific community in other words
keep that in mind first even the best of
people cheat out there and today
Milliken is being considered that he not
only cheated a little bit but he also
apparently brushed aside the guy who
really came up with some of the ideas
that was Fletcher and that's just a
little bit of history there but anyways
the oil Drop experiment is a monumental
experiment I love it you know I think
it's it's uh it's good you know that
they do experiments like that and that
they determine things like you know what
is the charge on the electron just for
the sake of having a value and being
knowing you know how to use these things
we say well you know whatever one
Coulomb is this is one point six times
ten to the nineteenth negative in the
case of an electron positive case of
proton so it's nice to have those
numbers they can be used in technology
you know it gives people's ideas they
know get an idea of what quantities are
working with so in that sense you know
it does it does help this this is good
so nothing wrong with the experiment at
all
what is the rope model of because see
one thing that Milligan could not
explain it to this day no one can
explain in quantum mechanics is you know
what is a what do you mean you remove an
electron and we all understand that as
saying okay if I remove an electron
right from an atom it changes the
characteristics but what are we removing
well we're removing a little bead that's
the official version you have the proton
and we're just gonna deal with the
hydrogen atom just for sake of argument
here we have the proton in the center
and the electron bead running around it
outside of it and what happens if you
remove the electron bead somehow this
thing has a positive charge what's left
it's a positive ion and the electron has
the negative charge that was taken away
that's how it's explained everybody
understands that because it's a very
straightforward explanation it's a
kindergarten stuff that anybody can
understand what we can't understand is
what kept the electron tied to the
proton in the first place that's where
we run into trouble you know there were
the model of the atom this planetary
model is what's what's wrong
that's okay to explain ionization in a
very simple way to kindergartner he'll
understand man
but don't tell me you know them don't
tell someone out there that that's what
Mother Nature actually has out there and
again we have a problem with the
structures the architectures that
quantum mechanics proposes what is the
architecture the rope model well it's a
little more difficult it's made of
balloons and here I found the best
analogy for how you have you're supposed
to look at this from the Rope model and
here what you have essentially is you
know the peach D s shell and the P
shells that's what they some what would
look like the P shells would be in
orthogonal to each other that's the way
you're supposed to think of it here I I
just took a flower made of balloons
right just to make the point just
explain how we look at this thing and
what we have here is that if you remove
one of those balloons you pop one of the
balloons what you have is an ion okay
that's what under the Rope model what
you would consider ionisation one of the
balloons dis inflate 'add for whatever
reason and and so you're missing one of
the petals in this case a pea shell okay
and that would apply to any level of of
an atom usually when we're talking about
this happening and happens to the outer
shell only that means that if this shell
is contained with this whole thing this
whole flower that you see there is
contained within an S shell a bigger
cell that contains this it would be on
the outer shell on which you would see
this happening that's the one that would
dis inflate or or disappear and so you
can see the model that the rope Pat
proposes is quite different than the one
that you know the planetary Bohr's and
brother forbes planetary model suggests
what is how do we do ionic bonds I had a
little picture here in one of my videos
and here you can see a model of it
that's an ionic bond you can also have
covalent bond there's also a hydrogen
bond there's different kinds of bonds
and what we're seeing here is that the
cells the the the electron shell has the
is made out of all these threads and I
call them the magnetic threads just
because of convention and these threads
are moving around the electron its part
it makes the shell it also spins around
if the if like in this case if the
threads are moving in the clockwise
direction it meets another atom or
another pea shell in this case that also
moves in the clockwise direction then
there's an attraction
always when attraction under the rope
model is either both clockwise or both
counterclockwise it's when they oppose
each other when one goes clockwise the
other one counterclockwise that you have
repulsion but when both are spinning in
the same direction then you have
attraction why because where's the
threads and one come down the other one
go up and that's where the attachment
occurs and here you have the two kids
they're jumping rope and that more or
less explains the mechanism proposing
now Mother Nature doesn't know what
positive negative is mother nature does
understand what clockwise and
counterclockwise is and so if if you
want to give a physical interpretation
you can't use the positive and negative
you really have to go in there tell me
what is happening at the atomic level
and give me a mechanism what this
positive mean right in physical terms
give me a physical interpretation for
positive and negative saying what is
positive look like right and that's what
I'm doing here I'm saying that from a
physical point of view
mother nature understands clockwise and
counter clockwise she can deal with that
she knows whether the earth goes
clockwise from a given point of view
compared to the Sun and that kind of
thing she understands you
talking about mother nature is anything
right right and just to show him like a
zoomed in movie like God's eyes movie of
what's going on in there you can't just
say positive you don't know yeah yeah
what does that mean zooms in with no
words you need to see the mechanism like
dominos you don't think explain domino
you just see it and see the mechanism
he's hitting each other the mute deaf
guy could just be oh I get it and you
can't say and you can't look at those
dominoes for example just to use your
same example and say well the dominoes
fall from positive to negative well you
can say that what is well nobody's and
as long as you're explaining the context
of seeing of what you're looking at you
okay as the only means where it starts
and where it ends right but if all you
say is right positive negatives this
electron is negative okay what am I
seeing what am i what is this deaf mute
guy looking at and that's what I'm
saying that you know if you say that
though that the dominoes fall from
positive to negative no one will
understand you other than you say look
positive is when they swear they start
falling to the left and you know and
negative is the one that you know the
last one to fall that's the director of
a positive the negative right right you
got a in order to understand what
positive negative means in that context
you simply got to look at the dominoes
and say okay I see what you're saying by
positive and negative you know there it
is look it I mean you could literally
explain all of these light gravity
magnets and phenomenons without saying a
single word you show me the movie show
me the mechanism
[Music]
a theory is a movie a theory to be I
mean real specific with it physically
speaking is is what on the language it's
it's it's universal where it goes beyond
me you don't need language for it you
could show that movie to Russian smart
kid doesn't matter who you show it to
they'll understand it without any single
words they'll set though they'll
extrapolate it and in their own words in
their own words tell the next guy kind
of what they saw but it should be a
theory should be able to be shown to
anyone without a single word I'm gonna
steal that from you see my kids a smart
kid and I'm gonna steal his intellectual
property now that that's good that's a
good analogy which or a good statement
what you said there that means that you
know I don't need to speak Chinese you
know I'm on an island and stuck with the
Chinese all I have is a video recorder
you know or TV or whatever that's all we
got out of the ship and there's a
Japanese guy or a Chinese guy or an
African guy with me we don't understand
each other's language and I'm gonna
explain to him a theory well I said just
watch the movie and so he watches the
movie he doesn't need to understand my
language to understand the mechanism I'm
proposing and that's that's very
important because objects or a movie of
objects of images is a universal
language self-explanatory it not only
that my favorite part that nefra is
self-explanatory you know take Charlie
Chaplin you know he did all these black
and white soundless movies at the
beginning century reversal comedy
everybody understands him everybody
knows and understands the plot and and
it's completely silent silent movie and
you say look I didn't understand the
plot because I didn't hear them speak or
I didn't see the words at the bottom I
didn't you don't need to you look and
you understand the whole plot just by
watching this guy doing their silent
movie and that's how physics is you
should be able to watch the movie all
the images and understand them the
mechanism right
imagine imagine doing us a little movie
on how a car works you're talking about
a car works just show a movie how a car
works from beginning to end you know
with all the parts going in there and
how something turns this and this turns
that and how the flow of gas and so on
and the guy if the guy pays attention
sees that whole thing he says okay I can
see he doesn't have to hear anything he
can more or less get a picture of how a
car works and you know if on the other
hand let's turn the tables around now
let's bring the mathematician in and he
goes in and he says okay PI R squared
and force equals mass times acceleration
and equals MC squared I'm sure I'm sure
no one's there gonna understand how a
car works with with n equation you put
up there you can put a series of
equation it's not going to help you at
all understand how that car moves
forward so so yeah the physical theory
is a movie and that's a good that's a
good comment there very good yeah it's a
universal language but I like the blind
man you know so he can get a picture
just by watching the movie he can get an
idea of your mecha no your proposed for
example gravity you know gravity I do it
with the ropes and you can see how the
objects approach each other and the
ropes fan out you know you get the idea
of the mechanism whether you believe it
or not is irrelevant I mean that's the
mechanism I proposed and all I want you
to understand my mechanism to be shown
[Music]
[Laughter]
at the love
[Applause]
against the wall yeah okay yeah
perfectly you know how did you pull on
the donkey with all this of the Rope
going through each other yeah and again
that's not an explanation see you're not
explaining something all you're saying
is that you're making an assumption that
that's what's happening yeah but he
doesn't know yeah yeah okay Greg right I
mean you can only all I'm saying is that
that falls under the assumptions okay
that falls under the like you can say
you know for example you say that light
travels at 300,000 kilometers per second
says well why well there is no why
that's that's just the fact no no all
I'm saying is it's now on I'm gonna
bring up
it's it's in the same boat because you
know some things you you just accept
because that's the way the universe is
you know the weight of the electron they
call it the mass fine we'll use the word
mass there are certain constants out
there that are god-given yes the way the
universe is I have an explanation for
them or a justification for them but
that's irrelevant again the point is
that it is a fact that light travels at
a certain speed some people say the
light has a variable speed fine but in a
vacuum just about everybody agrees that
it's 300,000 km/s it's been measures
been calculated whatever the point is
that we can rely on that number if if
we're gonna do something with it we're
gonna explain something in fact all the
equations of mathematics treated as this
constant even when it's not even when it
bends it's always a little C correct and
that's true
and and this is the point the point is
that physics science if we're going to
define physics or we're going to define
science as physical interpretations as
explanations then we should only have
movies and do it all with object with
the images we don't have to use any
equation in fact if you put equations
instead of images on the on the screen
nobody's going to be able to follow that
they're not going to get the the
mechanism if on the other hand you
define then you're talking about
something totally different it's funny
because when you when you explain
something to someone what you're
essentially doing is you're throwing
words at them so that they can be in
their head correct it is way easier to
just show them the movie so they don't
have to try to cut what you have changed
this this is what he meant explain
solely to them to someone else with
words he's drunk he's making a picture
inside his own brain I don't like it
an effective way of showing someone a
movie you get that but when I'm using
words to explain some yeah it's just a
crappy way of well I think it's
different and that's expound upon that a
little just for a second if I tell you a
story you know you're you're running it
in your head the words are going into
your ear you're immediately turning it
into images in your head you're saying
okay this guy went to the store he
bought a gun he went out there he shot a
rabbit you know you you can follow the
plot and you're you know you can kind of
wind it in your head you're that you're
understanding everything because you're
you're imaging it and saying okay I see
what what what you're talking about you
story but no no right right all I'm
saying is there's no images I haven't
shown him any images I'm using words
then he's creating the images by himself
in his head maybe the guy in his head
looks looking the guy in mud that I'm
proposing but that's zero the point is
okay because that detail is important
they'll have missed it you will have
missed because you think he got you yeah
but if it's not important like it but
you don't know what's important or not
because that part might trip them up for
whatever reason like was the gun red or
blue might be important to them like
that might be the important part that
they don't get but that's what I'm
saying the explanation with words I mean
it's way better to show the movie then
for sure they have the same movie the
you so that's one the second one is
second second best second best is to
draw images using objects again with
words we that's second best and third
and worse and absolutely non acceptable
as equations because if I just see not
accept it because isn't an equation kind
of like setting like again it's like
throwing all these descriptions there's
someone so they get the movie in their
head there are no objects there are no I
if I say force equal mass times
acceleration equals MC squared if I just
throw these equations out the guy's not
going to understand absolutely anything
of what I'm talking
no you won't have anything in his head
because there's no no there's nothing
but visualize yeah there's nothing to
visual and that's my point my point is
that I can still accept words for a guy
who cannot draw or a blind man you can't
draw if you get a blind man right I
can't show him pictures but I can
explain in words if he has these images
in his mind and he's gonna say okay I
still understand what you're talking
about though I can understand the plot
or I can understand your explanation or
your mechanism but for sure you cannot
understand him just throw equations at
someone you know he's not gonna he won't
understand the plot now among
mathematicians they talk to each other
they say equals mc-squared and the other
guy says okay I know I know what you're
talking about because they're talking
about abstractions they're just talking
about descriptions they're talking about
they're not talking about a mechanism
they're talking about a description
thrown out there of something that
they're familiar with already and so
they say okay ecomes mc-squared force
equals mass times acceleration PI R
squared whatever they get all these
notions in their hand so they they have
the abstraction of what the other guy is
explaining which is essentially motion
so he says it if you know which motion
you thought right yeah well I know what
motion you're talking about or or if you
turn mass into energy I know what you're
talking about or if you're talking about
time I know what you're talking what you
don't know exactly the plot or the
mechanism just by going to equations you
can't you absolutely can't I guess it
comes down to the fact that any language
is shorthand for reality any words I'm
using is like just one string of
information every word just kind of
gives you like a little like a fraction
if I show you a picture that's why they
see pictures worth a thousand words and
then you see a picture yeah thanks to
describe everything in that picture for
it explained just describing everything
in that picture
if I say if I just event just explain
everything everything goes in front of
me right now I have to read out and tell
you the shape of every single one of
those letters on the books the colors
the the reflection how the shadows play
is imagine imagine describing just
whatever you see just one just open your
eyes and don't move any time during your
life just wake up open your eyes and try
to describe that to a sketch artist and
have him draw it exactly how you are
seeing yeah it's not gonna work for me
it might work but it'll take you like a
week but you know something else if a
picture is worth a thousand words and a
movie is made of moving pictures motion
pictures then we have yeah you have in
the movie it's worth a million words you
show a movie and the guy understands a
mechanism period but if you go in there
with the equations so so again equations
is not the language physics the language
of physics to explain phenomena how
things run how mother nature runs her
shop out there the only way is with
pictures and that means you deal with
objects only objects can be image of why
movies or shapes or patrons is the
language of physics because the language
of physics is essentially universal it's
self explanatory when you look at it
when you I guess the better way of
saying is when you detected language and
whatever way the theory goes into your
head it should be self explanatory
without you know needing any special
training
baby I mean okay babies still need to
like learn how nouns at least no no no
worries
oh they learn not even pictures is how
the world were there you know gravity is
there still figuring the basic stuff
right well yeah but I mean like a normal
for like a kid let's say you like a 14
year old or a 12 year old you should be
able to show any movie like physical
movies
kid for them to understand what it is
you're trying to explain or how it is
their magnet works how it is the gravity
worse because essentially what we're
saying is if we had like a super
powerful microscope you should be able
to see what's going on right yeah like
the only difference is we just don't
have that technology but you think in
theory it'd be something that they did
like that you could see it's not it's
not like something just unfathomable
that when you zoom in it's just like
crazy stuff like you just see you should
be able to see something at some point
right if you zoom in really really close
to see what is the thing that's causing
gravity or what is the thing causing
magnet yeah yeah yeah God's eyes you
should be able to see something yeah I
think everyone has that notion in their
head was like okay if we had you know
magical powers to see what it is that's
actually doing these things what would
it look like that's one issue the other
issue is that all equations have been
derived after observing physical objects
first you observe a phenomenon then you
describe it with words or with math
whatever but first you gotta observe it
and and so you know math has always come
second to observation in that sense we
always observed first then we described
it with math and so you can't say that
with bath was invented prior to the
observation never it's always been in
reverse and after you observe something
you develop the equation yes you can use
it to say look I can predict where this
thing is gonna be in two hours now you
know the motion it's always no no not
necessarily you can say no no not
necessary because you can say look I
know where the earth is gonna be in the
next two minutes and it's not really
technology so it's an observation saying
I'm gonna see their earth over there if
you use right everybody want to use an
actual understanding right right right
and all I'm saying is that the
observation
leads the equation always so you know
it's not like they come up with the
equation then they see they say let's
see if this is true now first we find
out that it's true then we kept up with
you with the equation that's right
extract the important information from
an event so that they can use that
information or manipulated in some way
to predict something or do something
with that technology-wise we can look
and we build out of this information
what can we foresee with this
information what can we tell everybody
else about this information just know
and that's where people get the idea
that technology confirms this theory
that's that's totally not true
anyways charge that finishes the week we
had energy force-field and today charges
now you know yeah now you know exactly
what charge is it's a quantity it's one
point six times ten to the nineteenth
coulombs for the proton and negative
same value for the electron that's what
it is so we can't say we move a charge
because you can't move numbers no I
never used the word charge at all the
people who's just trying to explain what
they I don't use the word charged at all
never I never say we move the charge
you'll never hear me say that I'll say
you moved you know I don't even move an
electron because the electron is not a
bead so we got to think of an electron
to the Rope motto at least you got to
think of an electron in different terms
it's the electron shell it's a balloon a
balloon that covers or that encapsulates
a proton so it's a totally different
concept and I think that's at least
that's my proposal for how the universe
works and with that we'll see you on
Sunday and hopefully same time same
station see you then